speaker is Robert like I'm fine from
Christian technology everybody thanks
for the invitation today is a great
event here so I want to talk today start
my talk with the two experimental
observations discussed their
implications for how we think about
computation and learning in the brain
and then to introduce a theoretical
framework which integrates these
observations with our classical view of
synaptic plasticity so the way we think
about computation is very much and well
influenced by the starved computation
models that we have in computer science
like the random access machine and the a
Turing machine which is the classical
model of computation in theoretical
computer science and they of course
their main differences to how the brain
computes one difference I want to stress
here is that the Turing machine or the
random access machine is a static
machinery meaning that it the the
physical implementation of the machine
doesn't change during the computation
right so if you look at if you would
implement a Turing machine the way it's
done here like you what you wouldn't do
is you wouldn't just change like the
wheels during its computing or something
that wouldn't make sense right on the
other hand if we look at the brain the
brain is on one hand of course much more
complex then then adhering machine but
the brain we know for quite a long time
now that that it is a dynamic machinery
in the sense that its connectivity
changes over time
so even if you don't learn anything it's
there's no obvious learning you see if
you image the spines on dendrites over
days that there are spines which appear
spines which disappear so the spines are
the the site of the primary side of
excitatory inputs in the pyramidal cells
so this means that the connectivity is
change
the brain constantly and other results
have shown that this change depends only
on learning also on learning so what
they had here in this paper by Peters
2014 that they had a mouse learning a
specific motor task and when they start
with the training you see that what is
shown here is that addition of spines in
imaging sessions over over a time scale
of days and what you see is you have an
increased addition of spines in the
network which is followed by an
elimination process afterwards so what
we can conclude from that the
observation is the brain is wearing its
architecture in a tax dependent manner
what are the implications of this first
of all the connectome which we are
trying to look at and which will be
definitely an important contribution to
understanding of the brain does not
exist in the strict sense right so this
means of course there's a lot of
structure in the cortical network and in
the brain but on the final level there
is a refinement all the time and the
connectivity matrix if you look at it on
the on the microscopic scale at least of
synopsis can only be a temporal snapshot
of the evolving connectivity of the
brain all right
another implication is for me that I've
been looking quite a bit at circuits and
constructing circuits for specific
computations to understand computations
of the brain however we should have it
try a different view we should try to
see what happens if we let their
circuits construct themselves right can
they find architectures that are good
for the computation they have to do and
according to the data that we have the
brain is doing that in some extent and I
will argue I want to argue that this
synaptic rewiring so this
airing of the circuit is in this
necessary a mechanism for the brain in
order to achieve its a level of
performance and functionality that we
are used to okay
second observation is about plasticity
so when we work so this was all about
plasticity in some sense but if we look
at plasticity from the theoretical point
of view we often write it as a function
you know of so this would be a parameter
synaptic parameter theater and the
change of the synaptic parameter delta
theta would be a function of maybe the
parameter itself of some pre and
postsynaptic variables as well as maybe
global factors right now the may be
surprising maybe not so surprising fact
is that plasticity in the or synaptic
dynamics in the brain are actually to a
large extent stochastic okay so this is
from a robot walking and safe and they
estimated how much of the plasticity the
synapse or of the dynamics of a synapse
you can attribute the pre and
postsynaptic history dependent processes
and which you how much you can't explain
and is presumably this this is an
assumption now because it's not
completely clear it's like this but
presumably still has it would be more
than 50 percent okay the question is how
to arrive at that conclusion they have a
clever set up you know if you have two
two neurons in the brain and they're
connected connected they are usually not
connected by single synapse but by
several sign up cells and some of these
synapse is even target the same
dendritic branch right now if you look
at this pair of synapses which target is
same dendritic branch you it's easy to
understand that these synapses have the
same presynaptic variables right the
this presynaptic spiking as well as the
same postsynaptic they arose on the
branch like the branch voltage the
postsynaptic spikes and also dendritic
events and spikes there so one would
assume that if they have if they are
deterministic and a
changing according to the same learning
rule they would arrive at a similar
weight so what you can do is you can
consider the correlations between these
synaptic efficiencies of such pairs of
synapse is on the same day Android of
spare pairs of sinuses on different
dendritic branches and compare that and
you see that the correlation of the
weights of these synapses is actually
only 0.2 NT free so it's very far away
from highly correlated sign up is also
they experience the same pre and
postsynaptic variables and some work
equations leads to the conclusion that
there is a lot of these spontaneous
presumably stochastic changes how does
okay so
implications for that from that is
instead of looking at these
deterministic learning rules that we
actually usually get by looking at data
and fitting a deterministic function to
a highly stochastic data points we
should rather consider looking at rules
that very add basically noise to that
right and that's what we did the
question is what kind of noise should
you should you use there right and there
have been some studies about that for
example by Levenstein or as mat-su and
they have looked at the changes of spine
sizes over time and tried to describe
that with a stochastic model and the
model they came up with was a constant
one big process which seems to fit the
data very well right so one stanwyk
process is in principle quite simple so
that the part here is simply noise so
it's it's a wiener process in in
discrete-time you can think of it as
just gaussian noise that you add to the
changes and you have this deterministic
term here where you have your parameter
and basically the change if the
parameter is just given by the disorder
difference to some meme so what this
does is basically
it pulls the parameter towards this mean
mu and in addition to that you have the
noise right so we've out this here you
we would have only the noise and promise
would diverge
of course this cannot be the case so
this here kind of bounds the divergence
and what you get basically yeah right
is it's a stochastic process where these
theaters here are kind of pool to the to
the mean value but they are actually
stochastically fluctuating around that
and and to get an ocean a little bit
process actually the synaptic
efficiencies have to be proportional to
the exponent of this variable theater
that describes the evolution of the
synaptic efficiencies okay okay and when
you use that you basically get log
normal distribution of spine sizes or of
synaptic efficiency and this is what you
exactly also see in the data and many
people have shown that this log normal
distributed spine sizes are very common
in cortex all right so so this was about
the fluctuations now I'm going back to
the idea of rewiring of course what what
happens here is you know you have these
fluctuations here the the spines they
grow and shrink and and and when they
are becoming very small they disappear
right and sometimes spines will appear
and you get new Sciences there so to
model that in a simple way the way that
we thought about that was that we are
basically looking at this theater and
the theater encodes whether the synapse
is connected and disconnected if the
theater is the theater can be positive
or negative the way it can only be
positive so we only look at excitatory
synapses in this model but when the
theater becomes negative we say the
synapse disappears so the spine is small
it's not below some threshold and and
this times it's also disconnected
and but but the theater can still
fluctuate around hearing on the negative
on the negative scale so on the negative
side and and and when it comes up by
chance again
did you will see kind of a dendrite grow
again and the synapse is going to
re-established so basically theater is
small and zero if it disconnected
synapse if it's larger than zero we have
a functional sign ups and then if it's
functional we also have this exponential
dependence of the weight non functional
sort of silent sign artists and some
that actually non-existent so it's a
question of whether the sign ups so it's
just not there and then kind of kind of
even notice whether it would be useful
but these could maybe we actually doing
a distinguish between these two types
however here according to the
mathematics that we will have later when
the synapse is disconnected usually the
deterministic part will disappear or
like say they the the activity driven
part will disappear and you only have to
run a fluctuation so the synapse can in
in our modeling at least in the way that
we look at cannot see better it's going
to be useful or not it can only see
where it's useful very randomly appears
again so only functional selectors can
see whether they yes exactly
all right now now this is a kind of
describing basically what what what what
they have shown in the experiments but
this is not very useful right I mean
this network with this dynamics wouldn't
learn anything it just has this kind of
local normal distribution of spines and
so our main contribution is that first
of all we introduced this in reborrowing
and the second contribution was that
we're generalizing this to integrate it
with general learning rules yes
don't exist oh yeah sure sure so so
there are potential connections which
could be established and I mean in the
model that we're having basically you
could have a potential connection and
this one has like this dynamics and if
two neurons say they can't be connected
all because the action is completely
somewhere else then you couldn't even
have a potential connection
so in our model we have basically three
categories impossible silences so
potential synapses that are non-existent
there's all not established right when
the theater is negative and we have
established Sciences when the teacher is
positive all right so we are
generalizing this equation here and what
we're doing basically is we are chained
we are replacing this deterministic part
with a general term and this looks a
little bit odd but it's it's a it's
actually a standard term basically so
now what we are having here the channel
has to be a financial equation that we
are considering is one where we have the
noise term we have still the Vino
process we have introduced the
temperature parameter which scales can
scale the noise and we have this
deterministic part and we write this at
the monistic part in this particular way
and you will see why later and actually
this is a standard formulation if you
look at it we have some piece star or
theater here which can be seen as
something like a objective function that
you want to optimize with your learning
rule right and then we do some kind of
gradient descent on this objective
function okay so that's that's how we
can interpret it but we will see what it
does exactly later all right and this is
basically it we combine this with this
regard that I've discussed just on this
slide before
okay so what does it do now the analysis
goes as follows right because we have
the stochastic term you cannot say where
the the synaptic parameters will evolve
exactly right but you can say something
about the distribution of these
parameters right if you start somewhere
like one minute later it can't be far
off right it will not have been changing
completely so you can say there is some
distribution around this initial point
that you started at and then this
distribution will change over time of
course and you can describe this
distribution in this simple equation and
this is done exactly by the
fokker-planck equation which you don't
have to look at oh I just put it here
so that you see that it describes the
evolution of this of this distribution
of parameters over time and the question
is now what happens if you do let it
evolve very long right and what will
help miss under some mild conditions is
that it will it will reach a stationary
distribution which you which you kept
basically by using this equation setting
it to zero which means there is no
change anymore right and you get the
stationary distribution and how does the
stationary distribution look like you
solve that you will see 44 this
temperature being 1 if we said is to 1
it's exactly P star of theta okay
so what it means is when you have this
kind of plasticity process the network
is producing parameter settings which
are sampled from this distribution on
the long run all right so let's look
first at at the deterministic part let's
say this is gone TT TT is 0 so we have
the deterministic part only in this case
you would just have like this gradient
ascent on P star of theta so that means
if you start here you will end up in a
local maximum together with this noise
term you don't end up in a local maximum
but you're kind of always have this
noise around that and
we'll explore kind of the space and it
will reach every singles on the
long-term it will reach a single point
in the space with the probability P Star
Theater
so now P star in the top equation is an
energy and in the bottom equation it's a
distribution so that poses some
constraints on the energy function right
so you're doing a gradient ascent and
not descend on the gray in SN yes of
course it is non-negative its normalized
right in this case to get this
theoretical result it should be
probability distribution and it should
be differentiable twice differentiable
actually all right so for the if we do
this so it looks like it looks like this
looks kind of you know abstract right
for example of if you could use know P
star is being a Gaussian it's just a
Gaussian distribution a Gaussian prior
on the parameters if you do that you you
get back the orange tan limbic process
and then the network samples from a
Gaussian distribution over the theaters
and because the the the the weights we
are exponentially related to theta you
get a log normal distribution of it
right so this just is an example that
you see how you can use this in the
simple theorem okay now we have used
this general idea in the number of
different examples and used it for
learning in networks of neurons and
spike in neural networks so the first
example is an example I have used it for
reward-based learning okay so
reward-based learning is it is an
important paradigm for learning in
animals and humans we learn a lot from
rewards and there are many of course
experiments where we have this report by
setup so this is a you know a natural
thing to look at and for the word pay
set up how does this p star of theater
look like so in this case i said it's
kind of your objective function and
your objective in reward-based learning
basically you want to optimize or
maximize the discounted reward
give me your parameter so this could be
one part the expectation the expectation
degree worked and another part could be
some prior on your parameter say you
would like to have a network with sparse
connectivity or with log normal
distribution you can write this in this
prior and then you can have here so to
say the second objective of getting as
much aboard as possible and then P star
of theta would be proportional to this
product between these two factors okay
and now to what you have to do now is to
compute like the derivative with respect
to parameters of this and and in
principle this has been done often many
people have done this we have done it as
well
Gastner group se-young has done this and
it's just the basic thing so if you do
that what you end up with is a learning
rule which is a reward modulated or
imported get it STD be like learning
rule in a spiking your network okay so
okay I don't show this obviously but
you're assuming here you have now a
spike in your network you assume you
want to optimize the word that the
network gets you derive this learning
rule according to this equation what you
get is a rule where we have s DB updates
that are accumulated in an eligibility
trace and then when every reward comes
that the weights are adjusted
accordingly
so yeah I don't want to go into more
details this but this is more or less
thunder than what we add to this is not
a noise term right and this would give
you now an algorithm which does not
really optimize the reward but it
samples from parameter from parameter
settings which are good in with respect
to getting
all right so we've tried this out and we
tried it too to see whether we can use
this to to to model some data from
experiments and here we've chosen one
experiment from Peters at all where they
had the following they had a mouse which
was operating a liver a lever and
whenever it got a cue it should like
push the liver lever and it should pull
it back and that would give the reward
right so basically it had to learn some
kind of simple motor behavior and at the
same time they had imaging from motor
cortex and the motor cortex you can see
this assembly nice assembly sequences
there so this is two photon imaging and
you see after learning basically you get
nicer sequences there is less noise here
around as well as you get a better
representation of the movement directly
after the cue okay in addition they were
looking at the spine dynamic said this
is what I've shown you really before so
this is the experiment to this figure
where you see that there are spines
created when the animal starts to learn
and afterwards through some kind of
elimination okay so we made a simple
model for that I mean this is a
unstructured model of motor cortex so to
say we have inputs which indicates the
cue we have spiking neurons excitatory
inhibitory here and we have special
populations which control the movement
of the lever those one spiking of those
neurons would push it down and spike of
those neurons would pull it up and so we
use this reward more later but this is
the rule they are we use the rewiring as
well so what we have is just kind of a
circuit potential circuit structure so
to say in the structure is evolved also
during this learning with the rewiring
that we're having okay so the circuit is
able to
to trade the same way as any way
inhibitor humans are not trained the
only way only trained excitatory
synaptic connections right so the
network can learn that it also has
similar features than they have they are
so do you see as when we sort activity
of neurons before learning we see some
kind of sequences but they are noisy
after learning they are much less noisy
you get a better motor behavior so to
say which which basically solves the
task and you see that we have a better
representation of the sequence offered
directly after kion's it as there is it
here as to have it here and but what is
more interesting actually maybe is to
look at the dynamics of the parameters
so the dynamics of the parameters the
question is will it now like sample in
the space right as I proposed and so
basically here we have pca
of the high dimensional parameter space
in a network you start somewhere with
the synaptic efficiencies and also with
the network structure of course this is
also integrated and then it goes it
learned and basically after four hours
it finds a good solution the color here
says better the reward is good so
whether or whether it the movement is
done well or not right so when a red
color means we have good solution and
here we have a good solution but the
parameters don't stop here they continue
to change right so now here if we
continue training for 18 hours or so
they will still be a lot of change
however the movement is still very good
so the task is performed very well and
different way to furious is to few this
in a space where we have a
transformation into tasks relevant and
tasks irrelevant dimension in parameter
space so this is a hypothesis that
because you have like this large
parameter space there are many many
possibilities how you can solve the task
right there many different parameter
settings which solves a task and there
are some dimensions in this parameter
space which are relevant for your task
and others are not right now is this PC
a DPC a projection which extracts this
and then we plot the reward on top of
that to the measures you can nicely see
the reward depends a lot along this
dimension and doesn't it really depend
on the second dimension and what happens
is exactly what we are expecting is that
you start somewhere the network learns
to increase the reward and then it stays
somewhere there where the reward is good
everywhere right so the prediction of
this is that you will never see like
static parameter settings in in in in in
this in the brain but rather they are
always changing and even the
representations may change over time and
this reminds us of the changing of of
the place fields in an hippocampal c1 as
has been shown by safe yes right now
sorry what we did was at this point here
now we we completely perturb the system
ok to see what what happens okay we
perturb the systems and what we did was
we we reverse the functionality of these
two populations right now the the
network did completely the wrong thing
right and it just pushed and pulled in
the wrong direction and then we looked
will the network be able to compensate
for that and
and yes it did so this is initial
learning now we have this perturbation
now we're changing the way how the
network controls this lever and and it
does completely wrong afterwards but it
will after some time compensate for this
change which is expected to some extent
but the interesting thing is that the
the rewiring mechanism that we're that
we're using here is really essential to
do that if you don't have that so if you
would fix a connectivity at this point
and you would try to really relearn it
it wouldn't be able to relearn it and
the reason for this is that it has
learned a good connectivity matrix
basically for the task and this one is
however completely not useful for the
other tasks it should learn so it
wouldn't be able to compensate for his
perturbation so this is just kind of one
idea how this rewiring I could be useful
in terms of compensating for for changes
in in tasks or in network structure or
in any kind of parameter changes that
you have all right so all right in
addition to that we were looking at some
kind of characteristics of the circuit
of the dynamics and we see yes we were
having a similar kind of changes in the
addition of synopsis and in the deletion
of synopsis and when you do here this
this change in the task you see that a
lot of new signups s will be created
afterwards and then lagging a little bit
later you get a depletion of synapse s
similar as they have here I mean it's
it's it's only quality T afraid we did
not look at this in the quantitative
manner yes
bit of intuition of ethnicity if you
were sitting on top of one synapse in
the course of this process yeah during
this wandering process through a set of
parameters that all lead to good rewards
would you be noticing that one synapses
weight was sort of stochastically it was
with some kind of random walk looking
thing or yes you would see a random walk
looking thing yes my new perturbed but
all of them together would leave the
system in a high functioning state or
once yes I mean there is like they did
exactly the dynamics have two components
right the random component which
perturbs everything but there is also a
kind of a drift coming from this
gradient which tends to push it also to
a to a good task is really very simple
here I agree I think this I mean I will
I will show you later at a switches or
several tests which are much more
complex however not with spiking you but
maybe we can come back to this at this
point I mean in this case you're
completely right I mean this is a very
simple task it's it's the the network is
is very much over a parapet crossed here
just just note one thing you you
remember this this stuff we had in the
beginning about the the estimated
stochasticity of synapse is the question
is does our model fit to that and of
course in our model we cannot really say
that because because we have this
parameter T and this chain like this
scales how we're how much you would have
here of this blue part right but we can
say one thing let's look at the circuit
and it look at let's look at
temperatures where you are having a good
performance right and we see that there
are temperatures there's a like a
broader range of temperatures very good
performance so between 0.5 so this
temperature too romantic it scales the
amount of noise in the learning rule
right and if you look at something here
you see that in this range you get
similar results and you also get similar
yeah estimated hostility of the silences
it's just the sanity check it's just
showing you that we're not completely
off basically the data okay but now I
want to shift gears a little bit now but
we're this task is really simple right
and any kind of people guy who's working
imagine I would say okay what what's the
point right now we were thinking about
how can we apply this to a much more
complex task okay the problem at the
point when we were doing that was it was
really hard to train spiking your
networks for complex tasks now today
it's different thing we can do much more
you will hear this in the later talk but
at this point we were just thinking
let's the the the framework is so
general you can apply it basically to
any kind of network model and any kind
of learning model right so then the
framework just this is the whole
framework right it just says you have
some kind of plasticity you add noise to
that and you add this rewiring in this
very simple way right you can apply this
to add to it artificial neural network
and you can apply it for supervised
learning as well right and that's what
we did so we looking now at deep neural
networks supervised learning but using
the general framework for rewiring and
forced elastic elasticity within the
setup right so this is not telling you
anything about biology now but it tells
you something about what's the potential
of this this approach right can it
really be useful or isn't just like
these toy problems that you used to see
with spiking your networks now we did
that and basically we developed a a
learning algorithm which is based on you
know the standard back prop
now with rewiring and we
this noise and this algorithm we called
deep are and what it does is basically
we're taking at this prior now a
constraint on the number of connections
l0 norm constraint which means we really
constrain the number of connections in
the network we say throughout learning
we only want to have 5% connectivity so
a fixed number of connections in the
whole network right and and then you
can't just use kind of PD the like cross
entropy error function here to define
this distribution or something and you
get kind of a back probe which is
constrained to connectivity and which is
to some extent elastic okay this is the
algorithm we get and we apply this to a
number of proud problems standard
management problems we tried m-miss but
i'm showing you here
Seifer 10 which is slightly more complex
at an amnesty as well as timid which is
a temporal data set and and we use the
convolution network here and then we
looked at our algorithm tip R which is
in green here and see how well it
performs for different connectivity
percentages one hundred percent would be
a fully connected convolutional network
ten percent would be only ten percent of
these connections are really realized
but the algorithm rewire is those
connections throughout learning right
and what we see if you have like fifteen
percent you're really close to the
baseline of the fully connected Network
it's really very close here and in
addition at any of these connectivity
schemes here it's better than the
well-known state-of-the-art pruning
algorithm I handed out and the
difference is the pruning algorithm
actually starts with a fully connected
Network and then prunes it after
training whereas we started with this
parison network and and just rewire
right and I think this is really
necessary of course because you don't
want you start with a fully connected
brain and then rewire that I mean there
is some kind of
pruning we know that but but still
you're really severely limited in the
number of connections that you have in
the brain right so I would claim that
this rewiring is is really necessary
mechanisms needed to have useful a good
learning in the brain okay we did the
same thing we've timid here we use an LS
TM recurrent Network it worked extremely
well so here we were for example at 4%
connectivity we had very good
performance on this data set it's a
speech data set and just to give you an
idea what it means this is a fully
connected Network layer 400 euros for
hundreds hundred percent connectivity
you don't see any neuron you don't see
any connectivity because everything is
connectivity here now I prune that 4%
okay it looks much better right so this
is a reason they become activity scheme
and this is the connectivity matrix you
see it's nicely sparse and there's
something you could imagine that can be
implemented in a limited system alright
so let's go to the conclusions then I
want to add something to discussion we
had yesterday
neuroscience machine learning I think
I've shown you in my last part that the
ideas that we have in neuroscience can
very nicely be ported to ideas in
machine learning and as Matt Padmini
told us or was writing in his paper
about neuroscience and machine learning
usually it's not the exact algorithms
that you pull but rather these general
ideas like rewiring or something which
are very useful and I think the same is
true in the opposite direction
the ideas of MCMC sampling is not an
idea that came out of neuroscience still
it's something that we use to analyze
the dynamics of the connections and of
the parameters in our network all right
then we found that you can actually use
this kind of rewiring algorithms to get
good architecture so I would suggest
that we should make use
the self constructing capabilities of
neural networks which are proved to
exist in the brain and finally what we
can offer in this direction is a
theoretical framework for understanding
stochastic Network plasticity and
rewiring in the brain which unifies all
of that and with that I want to thank
you and they were thank collaborators
David couple who is did most of the work
on this spiking neural network rewiring
like gurram bellick who did the rewiring
in the artificial network and also
welcomed us of course who is very
important in all this work that we're
doing in the lab thank you
[Applause]
just by in the south would you expect
actual improvements if you would go to
cascade yeah this is a great question is
this something we do not consider it
alright consolidation obviously is an
important point because if you look at
if you think of it I mean it's nice that
you have like this in like this noise
there but there I mean if you have it
like this there is no way to consolidate
any knowledge of something right if you
would have learned something and then
you don't learn it for awhile you would
completely forget it because it's just
wiped out by the noise right so
consolidation is an issue and definitely
I would think that if you use some kind
of a cascade model which which you could
you could use that to stabilize memories
and consolidate stuff that you have
learned
um if that's another good question I
don't know that I just know the data
that that I've seen but about
consolidation yeah one would have to
look yes so did I get it right so if you
can afford the full connectivity that
would always be better than the proof
not necessarily not necessarily yes
actually I didn't tell you that but if
you look at this curve so here we're
having this is the baseline of a fully
connected lsdm from the literature so
your lower is better actually right and
this is with pruning it's better and the
reason is the pruning is or not from the
rewiring or they the constraint that the
connectivity is a regularized story on
the test that you're doing better so
another question Bartlett mentioned in
one of his talks that results when this
I'll the sign of this would be not
effective but they would be sensitive
sort of to whether they could contribute
or not okay I mean they're there but
they don't notice whether they would be
efficient or not judge maybe just sit
just to remark that it might actually be
interesting to consider sinuses that are
not doing anything but they're sensing
3% of the signal in order to figure out
whether they might be used right so this
goes back to this this these free
classes of having like silent sinuses as
well so we don't have this and we just
wanted to make sure in our model like we
say if it sounds disconnect mean it's
it's not a silent type Street
disconnected then it cannot sense
anything but you could have an
additional things of course where you
have like a pre-staged where it senses
and yeah
if there was another question all right
just to comment this be depend a lot of
what the learning problem is because and
also the area of the brain where you
look so this is a little known fact but
in the hippocampus when when people have
looked at the you know kind of done
eeehm and looked at spine size and
postsynaptic densities and so on there
appear to be two two classes little weak
ones were antha channels and things like
that
and it's but the the weak ones appear to
make up
I mean maybe those are we don't know but
maybe those are the silent ones up here
to make up 90% representing information
for long periods of time or don't even
get noticed because they're a tiny
fraction of the population whereas there
can be a lot of turnover in the weak
ones and there is a lot of turnover
which is always puzzling if you have
kind of a memory system why you should
expect turnover of synapses it seems
like it would be washing out of memory
so maybe that large population of
relatively weak synapses is primarily
sensitive on waiting for the moment to
be potentiated so I mean and you're
saying this strong was their really
stable right yeah that would be kind of
they're really built up big post up
densities perforate yeah thank you yeah
should look at it yes
you're stochastic rewiring ideas and the
diffusion of weights proposed by HP in
the context of stochastic gradient
descent always a good good point
actually
um right it's related I mean if you have
a stochastic gradient descent right you
have a noise which is introduced into
the learning by this torus this ax T of
the training examples that you see this
is some part of noise which you have
there and that could be seen as part of
the noise that we are modeling here so I
think there is there should be
relationship I mean one difference is
that in our case we have we are not
dependent on this noise on the on the
training examples or rather we add this
relate directly but I agree there is you
get some some amount of noise from this
elastic if we add the extra noise to
that exactly current I don't know this
kind of coming and going though possibly
weak synapses has any functional
implication so I move I have not two
papers when I hippocampus the other one
in ARP BC from Bristol and hawi
which soda actually went there check no
say the place L place else in
hippocampus that over weeks and did they
change substantially so this is this to
me then at least on this level of no-cut
neural codes now you see this plastic
drifts and code in the paper of this
cone having run last year it was no kind
of candy related new code for the end
behavior and this was also drifting
drastically over the set of set of weeks
then right so we could still be that
there's somewhere hidden skeleton which
doesn't change and right but at least
one has to say on the level of neural
coding but the record nobody sees ready
the cells respond differently big after
be
[Applause]